hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to escaping the prison
another game in the line of the steal
the diamond games with you guys actually
really liked and I'm happy about that
because I thoroughly enjoyed playing it
it was something charming about it way
back in the days of Newgrounds when I
used to troll that place all the time
but either way I'm back with another
game because you requested it and most
likely you may have played it by now and
if you haven't please do it's great game
they're a lot of fun you're free to go
hey a package useful yeah yeah of course
I checked it I mean if I didn't check it
out it was my job that was my job yeah
see me around sure you will actually
think this game came before stealing the
diamond I'm playing these totally out of
order of what they should be oh my god
that was all in there maybe I'll start
with a file surely if that could get me
out of here
oh I have so many choices again
cell door how is this not gonna work out
for me just questionable maybe because
it's almost impossible to actually get
through them Wow
holy crap good job guy hey I didn't oh
god didn't see happening you didn't give
me a chance I've got the reflex of a
statue
ah but screw you hmm okay let's try this
again I'm so ready somehow I know magic
ah-ha divine now I'm gonna get me this
time I am ready oh just the two of you
oh so much for losing your job you're
gonna lose your life and I'm out of here
wait no this doesn't help me it ways
that a belt of grenades that's level 2
grenades only is the belt a growth is
gonna kill me oh the guy from Myka rubra
oh man if any of you know what I'm
talking about you're probably done is
the game drums that would never mind
just use the chair chairs always good
cheaper so who's gonna get you out right
or left left led towards them
so by law of it probably doesn't want me
to do what I think it wants me to do oh
[Applause]
yeah that's good Oh patty well that's
not even fair to say alright fine
whatever I'll go write somehow that'll
magically turn out better for me
and I gotta get chopped up in the hole
the photos gonna get chopped up in the
fans thankfully this game isn't that
violent not like most of the other games
I have played they're just a lot of
choices
I imagine the most of the choices in the
beginning of the game wouldn't have
actually happened cuz if they all have
branches like this holy crap there's
gonna be a long video or there'll be a
lot for you guys to test out once you
play it if I don't get to everything
myself why this seems awfully familiar
I would know this if I'd played the
other games
I apologize for I'm gonna just play them
all backwards because I think there was
one even before this that was uh
something about a bank robbery so
probably break the bank breaking
breaking into the base break break the
bank I think it was there's so many
other choices here why wouldn't the
parachute work why wouldn't it pull the
cord man that's just unfair Oh that'd
kill them all that killed him Oh what do
you mean again never mind should I
assume that anything else didn't work
should I assume that this jetpack wasn't
actually gonna shoot ya it takes many
hours is that back training before
you're able to operate one I don't think
anybody has jetpack training because I'm
afraid to tell you jetpacks don't really
exist in that way actually they do there
is that suit that does it ah that is
true ok anyway starting back from the
beginning energy drink
don't know how this gonna help me Wow oh
my god
that was an energy that was just liquid
crack I've got about 10 seconds before
my whole brain just explodes you can see
oh my goodness
that's what Oh uh-huh
maybe because well I mean if the
instantaneous force you applied to that
bar cost to be able to pen picking up
that guy would instantly kill him
causing all of his body parts to explode
out of the instantaneous force if you
don't know what I'm talking about if you
a force is applied over a very short
period of time it implies that it's
going very fast and it is it would be
going very fast holy crap wait oh I died
anyway I was getting all sciency no one
wants me to get sciency Hertford am i
markiplier big gummy someone else from
the comments filling the red for me I'm
outta here I'm back now I had to make
sure that the power cord to my camera
wasn't on but whatever you don't care
let's move on alright teleporter let's
see how this is gonna suck it worked
last time
oh so the time that I actually did it it
works correctly oh I'm a name is
stealing the diamonds one rocket
launcher this can't possibly entera
bleah oh great what what do you mean way
to aim that was an incredible shot I
made how is that not gonna be bad
alright cell phone okay yeah yeah
attorney okay
Fletcher Reed why does that sound
familiar okay okay
witness please continue your testimony
okay
as right alongside my partner in the
armored man but generally spotted a bag
on the side of the road I got out and
eventually decided to throw the bag in
with the other we didn't know what it
was someone hiding in there perfection
oh so the defendant crawled into that
bag in order to break him to the bank is
that correct is it not obvious is it
really that obvious proof that the
defendant didn't hide himself in that
bag well then what are you waiting for
present this evidence already oh wait
what I gotta do something I was
suggesting the microphone eyeball this
oh no no I didn't play breaking the bank
ah that's gonna be so bad know what to
do I'm gonna play break the bank and
then everything's gonna be totally
obvious um mysterious device may yes
this what is this as evidence and how
exactly does this prove anything
[Music]
just kidding this is no time for jokes I
see no reason to further prolong this
trial
I find the defendant Henry stickmin wait
no what what do you mean I don't know
what I'm supposed to do
Lag take Wow is is that the bag the
defendant hidden yes but there's one
thing that's been bothering me if the
defendant really was hiding in this bag
then from the outside of the bag I think
it'd be possible from the tie that knot
on the outside what that meant I wanna
do it it's simple didn't you see I'm
saying my client wasn't hiding that bag
at all you're stuffed in there by this
very witness as you can see by this
doctor's analysis
defendant had taken quite the beating I
was in the bag
he was unconscious the PCs absurd the
witness was attempting to dispose of the
body
we left the defendant the bank knowing
he'd drive by it on the way back to the
bank when a witness and his partner
passed the bag he convinced his partner
to throw the bag in with the other what
but why would he do that
millions of Beggs money in that Bank
the witness knew take a long time before
the victim is found but unfortunately
for the witness his victim woke up and
tried to escape from the security he was
arrested on a spot any witness thought
everything was over at Wainwright
certainly was an interesting trial
however I am now ready to deliver my
verdict I find the defendant Henry
stickmin free that doesn't make any
sense because it didn't play the game
but I'm free baby free to steal diamonds
wait now lamenting how is that lame
those awesome I love Phoenix Wright is
one of my favorite games at least the
first two were but you know what I mean
a little boring after a while anyway
this is like the last thing cuz this
gonna do for me oh and horribly that's
what's gonna do drove right to the
center of the earth I oh no I'm
continuing crowbar headcrabs no
headcrabs okay alright then well that's
bad yeah I'm going so fast my hands are
blurring and my pizza's gauze dude okay
I won for me I went right
there's good ha ok right was also still
bad choice presenting me a choice that I
know let's go to trial and error it over
an Orion Zilla James let me quit how are
they missing with that shotgun so close
to me this is ridiculous oh go down time
to stop apparently because get ready for
what what am i doing what am i doing Oh
shinobi duel oh come on quick it's a
bunch of poopy ball I got do it all the
god damn it I'm up bad for through this
ah baby matrixed it up I caught one how
what all right I'm not gonna try to
understand physics in this game but this
doesn't make any sense it's like the
scene from V for Vendetta good the back
in the ugly the back big back
hey the Batman's ending that worked for
me I guess what else was there that I
could have done I think I got everything
everybody I think I got everything
also looks like the white balance went
way off on my webcam but that's okay you
probably don't even know what that means
main site went yellow so thanks again
everybody so much for watching
I will play more of these games because
as far as I know there's two more in the
series as the bank won and then there's
something that comes after stealing the
diamond I don't know why I started where
I did but hey it's what happened and
I'll just live with my decision to the
rest of my days take this with me to my
grave and everyone's gonna remind me of
it from days on end until I die so
thanks again everybody for watching
check out the other videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video
[Music]
I was hitting everywhere
Oh